rich countries are giving away more in
hade than at any other time on record in
2016
more than 140 billion dollars was
distributed around the world according
to the latest breakdown in 2015 America
gave the most money away nearly 30 1
billion dollars to at least 40 countries
and organizations such as the World Bank
this included seven hundred and seventy
million dollars to Pakistan and two
hundred and fifty million dollars to
Mexico
this may sound generous but the United
States has the largest economy in the
world American foreign aid spending in
2015 was only Saylor 0.17% of the
country's gross national income far less
than other rich countries Sweden and
Norway are the biggest givers donating
over 1 percent of their gross national
income to foreign aid the biggest
receivers of a's in 2015 were
Afghanistan India Vietnam Ethiopia and
Indonesia
Afghanistan received 3.8 billion dollars
and India 3.1 billion dollars
despite being the second biggest economy
in the world China received 1.5 billion
dollars in development aids in 2015
this included around 750 million dollars
from Germany and 67 million from Britain
the total amount of foreign aid is at an
all-time high up 9 percent in 2016 this
is largely down to the generosity of 6
countries who meet or exceed the United
Nations for an aid target
donating more than 0.7 percent of gross
national income